At this point,
the execution context looks a lot
like a collection of key value pairs,
sort of like an object.
Now noticing that similarity,
it would be tempting to
think that in memory scopes.
And in memory objects are somehow
actually the same thing.
This is a deceptive similarity,
since the two are kept so
completely separate by the interpreter.
And there are so many limits on
your access to an execution context
that don't exist to your
access to an object.
Many of the rules that
we've learned about objects
will also happen to be true for
execution contexts, but
you can never mix and
match the two in your programs.
Despite all of the similarities,
they live in completely different
worlds that almost never interact.
Just as a few examples,
you will never be able to
store an array full of contexts,
even though you can do so with objects.
You can't iterate over the variable
names in an execution context,
the way you would over
the keys in an object.
So even though they are both key
value data storage constructs,
you're going to be interacting with
the two in completely different ways.